if a hundred push-ups 100 sit-ups 100
squats and a 10 kilometer run every day
allows you to destroy the moon in a
single punch I wonder what like 10 a day
would do I mean I don't want to push
myself too hard you know
[Music]
[Music]
taking myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that can knock out any
franchise with just a single episode
okay today we're hopping back into the
wonderful world of anime to revisit one
punch man for those of you who don't
remember three years ago we actually
pitted his Unstoppable punch against
Captain America's unbreakable vibranium
Shield to see who could win but I never
quite felt like we gave the show itself
it's due from armored gorillas to
seaweed people this show is full of
absurd powers and awesome moments that
we could look at but of course nothing
compares to the Incredible strength
coming from everyone's favorite c-ranked
hero saitama I mean let's be honest who
wouldn't want to walk around with the
power to level planets at the end of
your arm well that power can now be
yours in your phone thanks to our
sponsor for today's episode one punch
man the strongest a new turn-based RPG
available now for IOS and Android the
game's officially licensed and
supervised by the people who know one
punch man the best recreating all the
key events from the first season of the
anime and not just recreating mixing in
actual scenes from the show it's a
really cool visual style that feels
unique to the game blending the Video
Game World with the anime World along
the way you'll have the chance to
recruit on over 60 fan favorite heroes
and villains ranging from Carnage Kabuto
to this Lost Child and of course there's
saitama himself whose Unstoppable punch
is entirely in your control no sit-ups
required well maybe some sit-ups
required considering you'll have to
complete his strict exercise regimen in
a Mini-Game mode Called saitama's Quest
you have to keep doing it no matter how
difficult it gets one punch man the
strongest is available now and it's
currently in the middle of its launch
event which means that if you go play
now you're gonna get yourself a bunch of
goodies if you want to find out more and
be a hero for fun you can download one
punch man the strongest by scanning the
QR code that you see on screen or
clicking the link in the description and
don't forget to use the promo code TFT
OPM for four super vouchers 30 stamina
10 000 coins and 10xp soda twos but hold
on let me stop Shilling here for a
moment well in theory having the power
of saitama in my hand seems awesome in
reality it'd probably be more like a
curse and not just because he's able to
defeat anyone without breaking a sweat
as I played through the events of one
punch man the strongest and remembered
all these bits from season 1 of the
anime I realized that saitama's heroics
actually cause a lot of damage and I do
mean a lot I know the show plays some of
these moments for laughs but when you
actually stop and do the calculations
one punch man has actually killed
millions of people in fact it's likely
that he's destroyed the planet multiple
times over in his carelessness in trying
to save civilization he's wound up
destroying it multiple times don't
believe me we'll hop off that bike of
yours for a second movement Rider cause
today we're talking about all the time
saitama's quote unquote hell actually
killed more people than it saved and
both one punch man the anime and the
strongest mobile game one of the first
villains we're introduced to is Beefcake
a buff dude bro who's mutated into a
giant mass of muscle in an effort to be
obviously though he's wrong he's
defeated by saitama in a single punch
who then gives him this dose of reality
having overwhelming strength is pretty
boring actually but I'm not interested
in the philosophy of it all I'm
interested in the resulting Devastation
when saitama punches Beefcake he knocks
him back onto the city crushing even
more buildings and killing more people
and all he has to say about it is whoops
it's a perfect Showcase of how he
doesn't take the consequences of his
actions seriously at all considering
that he likely just killed thousands of
people but to know for sure let's do
some math shall we first of all to
figure out how many people Beefcake
crushed as he fell we're gonna need to
find out how tall and wide Beefcake is
there's lots of ways to do this the
simplest is to take this profile shot
from the game and do some quick
measurements we see here that Beefcake
is standing next to this group buildings
doing some rough comparisons we can tell
that Beefcake is around six times the
height of the surrounding buildings but
something about that didn't seem big
enough so I decided to go back to the
original anime now in the series the
animators play with size and scale a lot
so I decided to go go with the biggest
scale that I could find evidence for and
it's right here when we see a footprint
left behind by Beefcake imprinted into a
huge portion of the city believe it or
not we can use this to determine his
height a person's height in proportion
to the length of their foot is typically
6.1 inch for height for every inch of
foot now due to the stylized nature of
the cityscape's art it's a bit difficult
to count the exact number of city blocks
here so to be safe we're gonna base our
count only on the very large streets
that we see cutting through the
buildings using that a reasonable count
will land us between five to nine blocks
so I'm just gonna split the difference
and say that it's seven city blocks long
an average city block in a large
metropolitan area tends to be about 1066
feet or 325 meters long meaning that
beefcake's foot here would be an insane
7464 feet or
2275 meters long that is the length of
six cruise ships or a long Airport
runway and again I recognize how
ridiculous that number is but that's
what the show is telling us so using our
6.1 inch to 1 inch proportion here that
means that Beefcake is an absolute unit
standing at 45
560 feet or 13 877 meters tall for
contacts the tallest building in the
world the Burj Khalifa is only
2717 feet or 828 meters tall this puts
beefcake's head firmly in the
stratosphere he is taller than the
altitude at which most planes fly
thankfully now that we have this number
figuring out how wide Beefcake is is
super simple thanks to our old trusty
friend pixel measurements we get
ourselves a good shot of beefcake's
entire body here using some basic math
we can determine that beefcake's body
has a width of roughly 16
345 feet or
4982 meters this is a very very rough
estimate but that would mean the
beefcake's entire body has an area of
roughly 26.7 square miles or 69.1 square
kilometers now before I move on to just
how destructive saitama's punch would be
here I want to challenge you to head on
down below this video and punch that
subscribe button go on I'll just wait
here and play through a chapter of one
punch man the strongest real quick I'm
at the chapter with Beefcake should be
one punch super easy so how many people
died when saitama knocked Beefcake over
well it would depend on a ton of factors
of course did Beefcake fall in a
commercial or residential area what time
of day is it how many people were able
to evacuate it's a lot of factors that
we don't really have a way to account
for so we're just gonna use a city-wide
average to keep the numbers as clean as
possible all of the cities in one punch
man are original creations with no great
one-to-one real world comparison but
since one punch man is a Japanese series
these cities have Japanese inspired
architecture and are shown to be densely
populated we're gonna use the stats for
Tokyo in our calculations Tokyo has a
population density of
6158 people per square kilometer which
means that about
425
518 people would have been crushed to
death just because saitama punched
Beefcake and knocked him back into the
city well done thousands it's a perished
you're right they did and you certainly
were responsible but some tells me it
wasn't in the way that you anticipated
so that is a lot of damage done to the
city and its inhabitants because of
saitama's recklessness but believe it or
not that's the least destructive thing
that we're talking about here today
because a few episodes later saitama
does another heroic Thing by punching a
meteor that's about to crash land into a
different city now he might be thinking
that saitama saved the city here he
destroyed the meteor before was able to
strike the planet that's a net win right
nope I'm here to tell you that what
saitama did might have actually been
worse than letting the meteor hit see
this meteor is described in the show as
a nine on the Torino scale elevating
from six to nine on the Torino scale
this is a real system of measurement
that looks at an asteroid's diameter and
How likely it is to hit Earth obviously
a nine on that scale is gonna be really
bad just for a frame of reference here a
10 is like the impact that killed the
dinosaurs now in that previous theory
that I mentioned before we found that
saitama's meteor was closest to the real
world asteroid 101 955 bennu which has
itself a diameter of 100600 108 feet or
490 meters and an approximate mass of
171 billion pounds or 78 billion
kilograms this thing is heavier than the
entirety of the Great Wall of China
considering meteors enter Earth's
atmosphere at a speed between 20 and 72
kilometers a second we calculated that
the meteor had 202 quintillion joules of
energy obviously that is going to be
devastating if it touches down but
here's the thing saitama's punch doesn't
gently stop the meteor fling it back
into outer space it makes the whole
thing explode see when the meteor is
suddenly stopped all that energy has to
go somewhere all saitama did was make it
explode up in the air even if we assume
he's somehow able to dissipate or absorb
like half the meteor's energy with his
punch that still leaves us with an
explosion equivalent to 24 million
kilotons of TNT I tried to get myself an
idea of how large a nuclear explosion
that would be just so we could visualize
it but when inputting that number into
our good old friend nuke map they
politely apologize that they didn't
calculate nuclear weapons that powerful
in fact the maximum that they allow in
this calculator is a a hundred thousand
kiloton bomb which would be over 240
times weaker than the explosion from
that meteor just get a sense this is
what would happen to Tokyo if a hundred
thousand kiloton bomb exploded 5 000
feet into the air now imagine something
that's 240 times worse here's the Good
News by punching the meteor and causing
the explosion up in the air
theoretically saitama would have caused
less damage to the impact area this is a
concept called air burst a term used in
Military Arms to describe explosives
that detonate in the air it means that
the peak energy of the explosion
wouldn't be on the ground in the middle
of the city so the absolute worst of
that explosion wouldn't be at the heart
of downtown the bad news while Air
Bursts are used in military weaponry to
cause damage over a wider area so a
greater percentage of the city and its
surrounding area are destroyed and
mid-air explosions of meteorites yeah
they're no joke they've actually
happened on Earth before in June of 1908
a 60 meter meteor exploded in the air
above Siberia causing a Shockwave that
flattened 80 million trees over an area
half the size of Rhode Island and that
was a meteor that basically was a tenth
the size of the one that saitama punches
here so rather than focusing the
catastrophic destruction in a single
area saitama managed to spread a
slightly less destructive force to a
much wider area while creating a
devastating shock wave in the process
additionally when a meteor explodes in
atmosphere pieces of it are still gonna
rain down and hit Earth and sadly unlike
one punch man the strongest where the
pieces from the meteor explosion
transform into new characters that you
can recruit it's not nearly as fun when
it happens in the real world side note
yes this is a real thing that happens in
the game the meteorite is like a giant
Interstellar Easter egg with treats
inside real talk I love that they
Incorporated that part of the show into
the game just a really fun way to handle
the character recruitment mechanic to
the anime's credit this is actually a
problem that they've thought of if I do
happen to take it out what then the
meteor may break apart and still cause a
disaster
I guess that takes care of that
I think the real world destruction here
would be far far worse than what we see
in the show obviously it's difficult to
math out how many pieces this meteor
would break into or how big they'd be so
I'm choosing a number here arbitrarily
assuming that half the meteor was
vaporized by his punch that still leaves
85 billion pounds of meteor left if that
broke up into pieces that were roughly
the size of a refrigerator that would
leave over 2 million rocks raining down
onto the Earth doing some back of the
napkin math here each would weigh nearly
18 000 kilograms and possess a kinetic
energy output equivalent to 11 kilotons
of TNT the atomic bomb dropped on
Hiroshima it had a yield of 15 kilotons
of TNT so at least the Rocks wouldn't be
as bad as that particular atomic bomb
but you know now there's two million of
them all hitting the area at the same
time kinda makes you wish that all the
meteor fragments really were just
characters like bang and boros like they
are in one punch man the strongest huh
and yet somehow somehow that still isn't
the worst thing that saitama's ever done
no that honor comes at the very end of
the season see during the final battle
of season 1 the alien Invader boros
knocks saitama to the Moon of course
saitama is completely unfazed and jumps
back to Earth with the power of His jump
creating a massive shock wave on the
lunar surface why is that a big deal
well this single action just doomed all
life on Earth let me explain since we
just talked about meteor impacts I
thought it might be fun to use the
crater saitama left behind on the moon
to calculate his energy see this thing
is huge big enough that it can be seen
from Earth we actually get a great look
at how massive it is in this piece of
artwork from the one punch Man manga
which allows us to measure its exact
width the diameter of the Moon is 2159
miles or 3475 kilometers and using pixel
measurements we can determine that the
crater is a gargantuan 1 344 miles or
2163 kilometers wide that is just under
the distance from Los Angeles California
to Dallas Texas in other words that
single crater is about half the width of
the United States so with all that
information in hand we can now use this
meteor impact calculator to determine
the energy of saitama's jump and the
answer is this 3.89 times 10 to the 26
joules of energy yeah it's a kind of
hard to tell what that means I mean
that's 26 zeros so you know it's
probably going to be really powerful
stuff nearly 400 septillion joules of
energy which sounds impressive but it's
also like you know it's it's confusing
like what does that actually translate
to well first it's certainly bigger than
the impact that killed the dinosaurs so
we certainly have that going for it my
next thought was that maybe it'd be
enough to outright destroy the moon but
nope not quite to do that you need to
add three more zeros 1.2 times 10 to the
29th joules but I suspect saitama's leap
back to Earth had enough power in it to
do something equally bad deorbit the
entire thing knock the moon out of its
gravitational relationship with Earth
swiping left on us as it pieces out into
the rest of the solar system moving a
Celestial body as big as the moon would
obviously be a super complicated math
problem thankfully theoretical physicist
Jack Fraser goval already did the math
for us navigating those messy equations
to find that it would take approximately
2.5 octillion joules to completely
deorbit the moon just slightly more than
what saitama's jump produces but not so
fast that's talking about the whole moon
when saitama jumped he also atomized a
huge chunk of what he was standing on
it's difficult to gauge just how much
debris was thrown from the lunar Surface
by saitama's jump but I suspect it was
enough to lower the moon's mass and set
it free from its marriage to the Earth
but even if it wasn't completely
deorbited the enormous amount of energy
from saitama's jump would still push the
moon a significant distance further away
from the planet so what why would that
be a problem well loyal theorists there
would be a lot of changes to the way
that our planet functions for example
the days we get slightly longer because
the moon's gravity partially affects the
speed of the Earth's spin the tilt of
the Earth would also change as it's the
pull of the moon that helps keep the
planet tilted at 23.5 degrees losing
this tilt would change the seasons
making a more unpredictable and more
extreme with the big one the huge change
that affects everything Tides losing the
moon or even pushing it further away
from the Earth would absolutely
devastate title systems all around the
world see the tides that you see in the
ocean are directed by the gravitational
pool that the moon has on Earth it's
literally pulling the water to follow it
as it orbits the planet the further the
moon gets the weaker the pool and the
lower the tides if they weaken enough or
disappear entirely that means that there
would be no tides to churn up material
in the oceans which allows for Coastal
ecosystems to thrive animals like crabs
mussels starfish and snails would be
decimated by this as would any creature
that relies on them for their source of
food and of course anything that relies
on those animals would then suffer as
well but making water go up and down
isn't the only thing that the tides
control they also control worldwide
currents of water that span entire
oceans this helps to stabilize earth's
climate Distributing warmer Waters
around the globe without the warm water
driven by the tides European cities
would suffer much colder climates than
we see today the same could be said for
Eastern Asian countries like Japan and
China who rely on the Kuroshio current
to bring warm equatorial Waters North
without the moon these tidal currents
would disappear devastating entire your
continents when combined with the more
extreme Seasons from the change in
Earth's Tilt kiss Humanity goodbye in
short civilization as we know it would
come to an end turns out that the hero
Association was always focused on the
wrong problem saitama is the real force
of Destruction they should have been
focused on stopping so considering that
maybe it's best that we do keep
saitama's powerful punch limited to a
mobile device which hey thanks again to
one punch man the strongest for
sponsoring today's video what better way
to revisit saitama destroying the lives
of millions throughout season one
remember if you want to check out this
new turn-based RPG you can download it
on IOS and Android right now plus you
can support the channel by either
scanning the QR code on screen or using
my download link in the description
below and don't forget to use my promo
code TFT OPM so you can fight alongside
saitama and be a hero for fun for real
if you have any interest in trying out
this game you don't want to miss out all
the free goodies that you get during
this launch event anyway if you'll
excuse me I have to go get my 100 squats
in in the meantime remember it's all
just a theory a film film Theory and cut